cher à l'ancien chef alsacien le
haut-rhin et noir ont plus que jamais
l'alsace en commun en ce début d'année
avec frédéric bierry nous formulons le
voeu que 2018 verra la renaissance d'une
alsace politique et institutionnelle
nous y travaillons ardemment avec de
nombreux élus alsaciens et de nombreux
acteurs investis dans la vie locale
cette collaboration forte en entre nos
deux départements est plus qu'une
évidence c'est pour brigitte klinkert et
moi même une exigence celle de servir le
plus efficacement possible
l'avenir de nos territoires et donc de
l'alsace nous portons ensemble un projet
ambitieux pour l'alsace pour que chacun
puisse y construire sa vie ses rêves ses
projets
l'alsace a une culture est une richesse
humaine elle est profondément européenne
elle puise sa force dans l'espace rhénan
c'est cette alsace que nous voulons
promouvoir cette alsace moderne ouverte
et compétitive que nous avons en commun
les prochains mois seront décisifs pour
construire le projet d'une nouvelle
collectivité partager et approuvé par le
plus grand nombre
la seule fusion des deux départements ne
pourra être une réponse adaptée aux
enjeux d'avenir pour l'alsace ce que
nous souhaitons c'est que l'alsace soit
nouveau maîtresse de son destin
notamment pour son développement
économique et pour son rayonnement futur
dans l'espace rhénan ce projet pour
l'alsace nous veillerons à le construire
avec vous citoyen du haut-rhin et du
bas-rhin élus locaux associations
entreprises des initiatives seront
prises dans ce sens au long de 2018
sherzad à sienne cher alsacien nous
avons besoins de chacune et chacun
d'entre vous pour l'alsace à vous toutes
et tous nous vous souhaitons le meilleur
pour rubis 18